in five four three two one
ohayo gozaimasu sayonara
good [ __ ] shaking [ __ ] daikon
raddish [ __ ] I hate you salutations
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain podcast and I've said
this before and people have asked why do
we call it genius brain and somebody
wrote this comment that irritated the
[ __ ] out of me because he's like oh
don't you've been calling yourself a
genius but hockey is like no you dumb
[ __ ] it actually means it's sarcastic
completely missed the [ __ ] point yeah
you stupid stupid son-of-a-bitch -
conclusion guys don't yeah it only makes
an ass out of you and me I'm completely
fine with saying that just because that
person was not a fan of the channel he
just stopped by okay randomly okay we
watched that guide in yeah dick [ __ ]
yeah I would never speak to my fans that
way and it feels weird even saying that
I found it kind of makes me sound a
little conceited and which I don't like
yeah I say my people who appreciate the
content on this channel what I'll say
and that person was not an appreciated
so he could suck elephant dick suck a
[ __ ] donkey de vich you dingleberry
[ __ ] yeah you know what my head my head
that mamma's called what's the [ __ ]
gears going in my head that I didn't
know about you until JK news uh-huh why
the [ __ ] do you like go so much alright
I don't even know where to begin with
this because yeah this is by far what
you enjoy is one of my worst nightmares
ever let me tell you this story when I
was a kid so if you guys know I grew up
in a Christian household yeah growing up
in a Christian household there there's a
lot of talk about what do you call that
I'm not extraterrestrial what do you my
spirit and his little in his little dick
shaped finger nobody ever addressed the
fact that he had a finger shaped like
that that Sam Cassell looking
hey I got love for second cell but let's
be really looks like [ __ ] he doesn't
like et but growing up in a religious
household there was always talk about
like demons and angels and I don't know
that's a real healthy thing to have like
a conversation to have with the kid but
I remember because like I would have
these like recollections of my parents
and their friends coming over for
cooling of it yeah and they would have
at least prior circles yeah and they
would start praying in tongue and [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] and something that stuck out to
me as a kid was when a pastor told me he
goes you know the closer that you become
to God more likely that these demons
will come and attack you right because
they want to separate you from God right
and that's when I left the church
believe in God but I'm getting close to
an attack this [ __ ] like what the [ __ ]
yeah that's like being like what's the
call associated with the gang get you
ass beat why would I want that
but they should used to always freak me
the [ __ ] out and so when pastors would
say that they would tell me that yo just
just know that the closer you become
with Christ
Satan's gonna come after you more so in
the back of my mind was like I'm just
gonna be the worst Christian ever I'm
just gonna curse all the time this
channel called name is so comedy and I'm
gonna make people laugh
and I'm gonna do good things and I'm a
believing God I'm gonna go to church but
I'm cursing up a [ __ ] storm because
then Satan's kind of like I thought it
was a weird thing for these pastors to
tell me and during this time at this
church that I used to go to there's do
name Hans now Hans was dope like I think
to me like if anything if I wanted to
model my Christian self after was after
this dude named Hans okay and Hans
Moleman
it was kind of weird that his name is
Hans he's a Korean cat yeah if it was
Han it might be done like German is
shitty but the dude was just a really
cool cat and I remember one time I'm not
sure if it was Hans
it was Haun's that told me this story
uh-huh but he was talking about this
dream that he had
where we were at a retreat yeah you guys
don't know what her treat is like a
spiritual retreat they take these kids
we go into like this camp side and we
just played games we get to know God we
worship we praise and we have a good
time it's a good bonding moment yeah so
Hans was telling this story that that he
had a dream one of the nights that we
were at the retreat he said that one he
fell asleep in the dream he has eyes
awoke and it wasn't I'm not sure if he
was saying it was a dream or if it
happened in real life but to him it felt
like a dream but when he he woke up but
he couldn't move so he had colleagues
scissor like yeah and so when he opened
up his eyes he saw a demon start flowing
floating down to him yeah and this demon
was approaching him slowly and this is
like in the cabin that we're all
sleeping together
yeah he said the demon came down and it
went inside his body and ripped out his
soul and he's watching it but he can't
do anything right as he's frozen his
rock and he's watching his spirit just
being ripped out of his body and dragged
out and seized the person just grabbed
him and just dragged his spirit out and
they start to float away and as that
spear started flow away he sees his
spirit struggling and fighting against
the demon that's [ __ ] crazy right and
this is during the this he's telling
this after after the fact right but he's
telling this to like a [ __ ] 10 year
old kid Yeah right but he's told and is
still stuck in my head till this day he
told me that when he was floating away
or his spirit was floating away from his
body he was his spirit was struggling
and pushing that demon away and then
when he like loosened up the grip of the
demon his spirit came down and fell into
his body and he woke up from this is a
lot yeah and he was he was like next to
us yeah and that should always freak me
the [ __ ] out like the thought and
because I really did look up to Hans
like it became something that was a
matter of fact to me like this could
happen to me a day yeah and everybody
has those similar symptoms when they
have scissor lock right is that you
can't move in you see like this black
figure cetera have you ever had that
before I did I had it once before hmm
[ __ ] that [ __ ] dude oh my course up a
storm don't come after me I believe in
God but my experience was kind of trippy
cuz like I was sleeping and then all of
a sudden I woke up but I was watching
myself sleep right oh so I was like
confused
what the [ __ ] cuz I feel lucid but I'm
watching myself sleep right now and then
so I'm looking at myself and my body's
like this way but I'm like looking at
myself straight on and then all of a
sudden I started to kind of float right
towards my body right you're talking
about the the you outside of your bodies
yeah toward you yeah yeah yeah so I'm
like floating to my body and then when I
get close to it it's like boom and then
my perspective now changes not laying in
bed and and I'm looking up in the sky or
I mean on the ceiling and I can't move
and I'm like what the [ __ ] right I'm
like is this what I think it is you know
am I getting copy right now right yeah
and then all of a sudden to the left of
me which is where I was looking at
myself from I just feel something I
can't I can't turn my head right and I
just feel something there and and it's
like [ __ ] this fear sets in to me
that I've never felt in my life before I
know I know what you're talk about yeah
I'm like why the [ __ ] am I so scared
right now right yeah and I can't see it
but I feel it getting closer to me kind
of like what just happened with me
moving towards my body nice bones yeah I
feel it coming closer and closer and
then I'm like starting to feel more and
more fear and I'm like starting to sweat
now and I'm like [ __ ] but then I feel
helpless - yeah I had a snap I got so
[ __ ] pissed that this was happening
to me it started I made a fist I was
able to make a fist in in that lock
state right and then I was like man if
this is [ __ ] what I think it is I
laughs [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know
you don't [ __ ] hold me down right and
then I started to get really angry and
then like my fists started to shake and
then I like broke out of it yeah and I
and I sat up and it wasn't like that's
when I woke up I was already awake like
my my train of thought didn't break it
was it was continuous and then I got up
and I was like what the [ __ ] was that
[ __ ] about you know that's the only
first and only time I've got says and it
happened maybe about three four years
ago that's such a weird experience and
everybody has their own experience with
it right and it's it's it's frightening
because you can't do anything about this
impending doom that's coming closer and
closer to you yeah so a lot of the
stories that are
from people was when they get says a lot
like if they were on their side yeah
their eyes would be open and they would
see this this figure has that figure
that that darf is always there and it's
it's either eyes staring at ya you can't
do anything about it and that person
staring at ya and I don't know why and
the thing that creeps me out is that
everybody has that similar experience I
know man
that's the part that creeps me out if it
was like for example drugs and when we
talk about drugs and people go on like
DMT and yeah yeah everybody has a
different experience so it makes me feel
like it's not this they're like well
it's an outer dimension that you go to
so well if it's an outer dimension that
you go to and everybody's doing
deorbiting system you should be able to
see that person who's in that DMT world
or you guys should be able to meet up or
something right but that doesn't happen
yeah or I haven't heard of a case where
it did yeah but the thing about that
scissor lock thing is it's it's it's
already consist it's consistent yeah and
it freaks me the [ __ ] out and it doesn't
I don't even think it necessarily has to
be people who are religious yeah yeah
yeah and cuz sleep paralysis is a weird
thing I mean a real thing that could
actually happen right yeah that that you
can explain that through science but how
how do you because sometimes how I think
science would explain it in terms of
like seeing the dark figure as you're
hallucinating yeah because yeah you're
going through this dance everybody's
hallucination the same thing no but
that's the thing it's like some people
I've had friends who got choked by the
spirit and then when they wake up they
have like red rings around their neck
and they came to you about this [ __ ]
scissor like I had it was the best
[ __ ] of my life it was like they
shouldn't a scary movie were there they
[ __ ] against the wall yeah but you
know I've heard some pretty crazy [ __ ]
man you know me tell you [ __ ] a true
PS story yeah yeah I had I had a friend
who used to be like super religious
right and then around like when we were
kind of in the middle of her teenage
years he started to get really bad you
know because like he's he he didn't
really associate with like a lot of I
guess me and some of my friends at the
time but once he started to then he
started to get like really bad you know
and then he kind of lost his way with
his religion in his faith
and then he tried to kind of get back
into it I think towards like the end of
high school and then so they were at a
retreat one of my other friends was
sitting on the top of a bunk bed on the
second one right and this guy was like
trying to walk out and then he was like
yo where you going right now it's just
late at night right no [ __ ] joke
this will [ __ ] turned around and like
looked at him like just like enough
weird [ __ ] like stared at him right
and he threw him from one end of the
bunk bed to the other like he lifted him
and pounded him to the back of the the
wall on the bunk bed and the guy was
just like what the [ __ ] just happened
right now yeah so who knows how to
explain that but he was possessed you
know that's how we would say right like
this guy was [ __ ] possessed and he
went off into the [ __ ] dark forest
where it's pitch-black and people went
out to go look for him he was just
kneeling over a river just looking into
the river asking if they can see what
he's seeing what the [ __ ] yeah what did
he see
I don't know I don't know he's just like
do you guys see that
I see what he's like that did he wake up
and then he was like what the [ __ ] could
I do I don't even know if you remember
it I don't think he does but this was a
type of dude once he like what a
roundhouse kick him in the [ __ ] jaw
dude I think you probably would have
caught it you would have probably ended
you then we'll see dude we'll see we'll
see about that how big was he how much
did he weigh with me on steroids the
power well I got the power of Jesus
Christ we'll see who's gonna win we'll
see Satan or Jesus Christ dude I'll put
the shin guard have the holy Christ on
me good and I will Shin kick that
[ __ ] all the way to the heavens
no but like for me man like my
infatuation with it is just like it's
unexplainable right there's you know
that there's something out there
nobody can say definitively what it is
or what it isn't yeah so I'm an
infinitely curious person man I'm cute
like my curiosity knows no bounds you
know even morbid [ __ ] I'm curious about
you know so like something like this I
just wanna I just want to have a more I
just real experience with it where I see
something or like something Christ inner
Y man like like even for me a big part
of me does believe that there are
spirits out there right that it's it's
true it's there yeah you know what you
are dude you're a [ __ ] faceted white
girl in a horror movie that's what you
are dude you think you're the
[ __ ] that hears something and
you go who's there and then you go
inside that room and you try to see
what's up what's wrong with you man
that's what f of Z is always talking
about man you [ __ ] with your ghost
boners and [ __ ] ain't a fetish dog like
[ __ ] I don't understand why you like to
test that [ __ ] did you ever do that we G
bored stuff I did I did yeah yo you have
a weird experience to hell [ __ ] yeah
I did
you know why you know why because I was
in a [ __ ] cemetery late at night whoa
dude you are a [ __ ] white girl and
then an end of the dudes who were
[ __ ] with the Ouija they were all
strangers I didn't know any of them
right well how did you guys meet up they
were just no no they were just there at
the cemetery they happened to be there
and I went to the cemetery - by yourself
no I was with some other people but then
they were there and then they were
playing with the Ouija board so I was
like oh you know what I was going to try
this let me [ __ ] with this right and
then gently okay and then they did let
their little [ __ ] thing though seance
or whatever right and then we got into
it then why people want this oh yeah I
[ __ ] know yeah how do I [ __ ] know
here was the thing is like I was like I
knew exactly what question I was gonna
ask was like what's my first name
because nobody's gonna [ __ ] guess
that right and if they spelled it
correctly yeah so so real [ __ ] there was
four of us right three so all four of us
have our hand on it but I Loki did not
put my hand on it all the way because I
didn't want to like subconsciously
influence the movement right they
started and I said okay what's my first
name
and then that ship moved to e and went
to D and then went to R that's when I
[ __ ] was like yo stop stop as I cut
that [ __ ] out I don't need to see where
the because even guessing up to R that's
like much idris elba that's what it was
what else would that be exactly that's
creepy dude yeah [ __ ] that yes I I had
to [ __ ] with it you know cuz I was
always curious about it cuz my cousin
told me I remember she was in college
and then she [ __ ] with the Ouija board
and she got into a [ __ ] bad car
accident that night maybe coincidence I
don't know but she was always like hey
don't ever [ __ ] with that and then you
did it anyways just like what you were
saying before somebody tells you not to
do it I got it yeah but a ghost [ __ ]
though I would spiritual stuff
especially with witchcraft that's the
devil's work young man that's that Harry
Potter I don't mess with that Harry
Potter than that Pokemon hey you know
what though man I've had my handful of
like paranormal experiences though and
and I have seen [ __ ] but from the corner
of my eye I saw but see this is what I'm
saying man you had the Ouija board
experience what possesses you to go
after it again you had your experience
you had it you got you got your [ __ ]
go fix something like more visceral you
know what I mean if you would have
continued it did I I don't know who told
me this story but there was somebody who
did a Ouija board experienced himself
and I forgot who they did it with but
when they were doing the whole Ouija
board thing I guess how they were saying
it that you could have a a happy spirit
or an angry okay and so the the the the
first time that they did it it was like
a happy spirit okay and the second time
that they were doing it on the spot and
they were doing the whole Ouija board
stuff it was an angry spirit and so when
that happened like things were like
flipping out or some [ __ ] they had to
tell them like hey like please please
leave please leave like we don't want
any harm like I'm look we apologize
please leave please leave too late he's
a too late mother [ __ ] but they did
leave and then like [ __ ] calm down after
but that's like the gamble that you play
you don't know if you're gonna get an
angry spirit or a happy spirit that's
the thing though doesn't that make you
curious of why there's an angry spirit
and a no it doesn't
bliss I'm talking about - like arguably
- it works both ways so if you do
believe in ghosts and stuff you can
ignore those signs
there's probably signs that gods there
and I'm ignoring it on purpose
like I said nope like I'm like walking
on water and I'm just hydroplaning I got
these floating me I'm 200 pounds just
happening I just think it's fascinating
man like the unexplainable you know like
and that's like the same with like
aliens - you know like I'm just I'm just
really curious and fascinated by the
possibility of it and it's like until I
have that because I would I think most
people if I tell them the experiences
that I've had like from a paranormal
paranormal standpoint they would be like
I think that's enough for you to know
that there's something there yeah though
the Ouija board thing was enough but I'm
like nah but I never seen one like front
and center and it hasn't like interacted
with me don't give me I'm not trying to
provoke it sounds like that's what
you're doing that's not a that exact it
sounds exactly that's what you're doing
you're poking you're provoking the
spirits dude tell you something dude I
would rather yeah we're [ __ ] a red
bandana in a [ __ ] neighbor hahaha then
go to a [ __ ] cemetery see two white
people with a boogie board and join in
with it I told you about the time I went
to the haunted hospital - yeah you're
stupid see that's the thing - like so
edrick has been wanting to go to this
haunted hospital it's it's it's in the
LA area and I'm pretty sure everybody
has heard about it it's it's a was it a
mental asylum or was it a house so one
they had the main hospital and
apparently they had like kind of the
psychiatric psychiatric ward right yeah
and so that place is actually very very
difficult to get into number one if you
do want to get in there you know you
can't anymore even they they tore down
and turn into a senior citizen community
so they just put people on the verge of
death there cuz like if some of these
people have like dementia or some [ __ ]
or maybe they don't
I saw something as I go that's it it's
just crazy old Molly talking that
nonsense yeah so they built the senior
citizen so you actually got to
experience that place before it was yeah
yes so well prior to it being tore down
it was just very hard to get in there
because you had to have a film permit or
something from the city that allowed you
to be there yeah and and there was
actually a lot of security around there
and so he was trying to get him for a
long time and when you were telling this
story I remember you telling me that
Jeff was there because you actually
texted me to know John John oh yeah yeah
yeah Jeff John yeah but somebody texting
me within the weather was Paul you or
somebody you know do you want to go I
was like oh no what gonna ask me that
[ __ ]
delete this text I said I'll be there
immediately
Taylor butt-naked the goes boners going
you know was he with the with you there
John he wasn't um so man that's a good
man initially nosey couldn't even
because I took him there before you know
he couldn't even look at the building
from across the street he was like yo
I'm getting [ __ ] bad being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] bro just look at this smart now
I'm looking at that [ __ ] dude you know
you can't you can't acknowledge
something you don't see and you choose
to ignore who don't meet a crazy thought
one of the times that I was trying to
like break in there was a window that
was open so I had a homie give me a
boost and then I looked in and it was
like pitch black in there I couldn't see
what where I was landing into and I was
like [ __ ] should I jump in here and I
was like no if I get hurt though
that might that might kind of make this
a bad night you know so I I decided
against it those were one that was just
one of the times I tried to get it but
when I actually got into the hospital
and I went to that area it was a 15-foot
drop drop and then been stuck there in
pitch black dark with his dad dude maybe
maybe would have shattered your [ __ ]
ankle yeah you would have been one of
the spirits but yeah when I finally got
in there you know I was excited my
psycho [ __ ] I'm gonna [ __ ] explore
and I'm gonna check this [ __ ] out and
inside there was a point in time when I
did go off by myself yeah and then just
everybody else was like he's got stupid
oh oh yeah so there were definitely
moments there where something was a
little off I was telling you guys when
we're doing the JK news [ __ ] like there
was a spot where it was ice [ __ ] cold
you know everywhere else's room
temperature in that room but it's just a
Randall it would be like here is ice
[ __ ] cold
right I don't know how to explain that
it's just like I would stick my arm out
like this and then I just get [ __ ]
goosebumps because it's so [ __ ] cold
in that one zone and then what does the
big grab do you dude I'd be like yes if
you know these girls don't even want you
to thirsty dude I was like well you're
not gonna get anything so only attack
people I don't want that [ __ ] yeah um
and then I told you guys the phone
battery thing everybody's battery was at
like 75% or more and we turn on our
flashlights for maybe about 10 minutes
right within that 10 minutes everybody's
battery was down to like 5% you know and
they say spirits try to use electronic
devices to try to communicate I don't
know I don't know if there's any truth
to that but all I know is it was a
little bit weird that everybody's
battery got drained that quickly because
if we had the flashlight on for maybe
like 30 minutes maybe maybe then it's a
little bit more reasonable but 10
minutes to drain that much yeah and I
was telling you other people felt stuff
they heard stuff I tried yeah I'm pretty
[ __ ] up for this but I took him into a
hallway like other other group of people
came and I knew but both doors on the
hallway were locked shut
right I took him there and then I was
like okay this is the way out and then
we went to one of the doors and I try to
open and it's like oh [ __ ] yo this [ __ ]
wasn't locked before I was like hey I
think there's an exit the other way
though let's go the other way so we just
do this long walk down the dark hallway
to the other oh [ __ ] dude these are the
only ways in and out
I think the [ __ ] stuff you're a
terrible person people started trippin
like yo yo what the [ __ ] how are we
gonna get out I'm like dude I don't know
man we might have to spend the night
here so hard we're [ __ ] with the
wrong things man yeah what if what if a
bad spirit comes at you what do you mean
I knew that I'm ready for it you know
what are you ready for what are you
ready for what are you gonna do nothing
I'm just ready for the experience is
what I'm saying whatever guy nobody to
blame myself you know hey you know I
wouldn't be traumatized you for the rest
of my [ __ ] life I would be
traumatized man but but even movies like
the [ __ ] ring dude oh yeah [ __ ]
come on but that's like you know good
any Asian version of like how they
interpret spirits and ghosts that [ __ ]
is [ __ ] creepy you remembered you
when we were [ __ ] little and like our
parents would watch like some scary [ __ ]
that [ __ ] used to scare the [ __ ] out of
me I'm like dude what the [ __ ] man dude
The Grudge yeah that eyes me man
at what age though how old was I out was
still I was in high school when The
Grudge came out I think so I hated that
[ __ ] dude because here's the thing man
like when it comes to horror movies I'm
okay with horror movies with when it
deals with human beings so there's a
human being that's a psychopath whatever
guns talk the same talk braat braat
braat kill them all
you can't do that to a ghost no yeah
that's why dude I that's why I created
that sketch I ain't afraid no [ __ ]
ghost
cuz I'm telling you right now like
straight up if ghost let's say ghosts do
exist right and you end up being like an
evil whatever angry Spectre yeah well
I'm not gonna be mad at humankind if a
ghost kill me yeah you kill me I will
[ __ ] you ah - no [ __ ] and you have no
[ __ ] clue I would be it would be
literally a vengeful spirit going after
spirits I would kill every ghost out
there dude ghosts would be scared of me
dude like this [ __ ] is after us
dear because you how [ __ ] dare you I
was chilling I'm not the one that wants
you to come after him you go over to
this guy nothing I because they know I'm
a friend they know I'm ghost friendly so
I I encourage it I'm like hey you guys
wanna you guys need somebody to talk to
her you want somebody to interact with
I'm huge I'm talking about Tim told me
the story where he met somebody either
on a plane or when he was travelling and
he was talking about this guy said that
he was so hyper connected to spirits and
it happened to him at a young age and as
he got older I guess like when he chose
not to just pay attention to these signs
they eventually his powers or whatever
eventually disappeared but when it was
very prevalent and he was paying
attention to it he said that he would be
driving listen he goes through a [ __ ]
tunnel or something and a spirit would
see him nobody else sees it but the
spirit would see him in the spirit would
look at him
oh you can see me mm-hmm hey how's it
going like let's talk and he goes nope
I'm gonna ignore this I'm gonna ignore
this and he would just drive right by
her but nobody would see it but that
would be like a spirit whether it passed
away in the tow or not yeah but the
spirit wouldn't recognize him try to
have conversations with them and that
should creep me the [ __ ] out and he goes
well let's talk and I'm like the [ __ ] no
dude try to have a conversation with us
[ __ ]
I'm trying to [ __ ] deny your
existence right now let alone
acknowledge you right now you know
there's a simple explanation for this
schizophrenia maybe but he says he
doesn't have it anymore so he doesn't he
doesn't have those powers anymore
because he ignored it for so long
I mean like how do you [ __ ] even like
quantify that you know like oh I get it
I gotta work on this power and
strengthen it or else I'm gonna lose it
you know like where the [ __ ] does that
even come from
dude I've Tim and I when we were doing
Sam Foods we did this thing where there
was like a psychic yeah
you know you know psychics talk to
spirits yeah ever and they can see your
future or whatever whatnot this lady if
if psychics are real this one was just
full of [ __ ]
it's completely most of them and like
her she was she was so basic she was the
most basic psychic ever yeah I'm talking
about she might as well has just been
like the [ __ ] Jamaican lady on them
cards she um like she would ask me Oh
what do you want in life
uh-huh and I would tell her what I want
in life and this you just mirror that
it's like do you're not even trying at
this point you're not even [ __ ]
trying and then she and I just remember
her because she had the most plaque I've
ever seen on teeth oh yeah
like I could have if I slapped her in
her forehead like a layer of plaque when
it came off and she would have had an
extra set of teeth you know how the [ __ ]
does that happen like like the people
who [ __ ] have like that black [ __ ]
like on their [ __ ] teeth and stuff if
when you're not a crack it it's gum
disease and gingivitis
it's crazy thing man when Vanessa and I
were we went to go watch a movie it was
that movie with John Krasinski be a
quiet place oh yeah quiet place let's go
watch that [ __ ] and I just recently got
my teeth fixed so I didn't know my teeth
were [ __ ] up like in terms of how bad
it was cuz I haven't got my teeth clean
in a long time but I you know I brush
and everything else so I thought it was
we fine yeah but because I didn't get my
teeth clean and I wasn't flossing
regularly like I had like some puffy
gums here and there okay and Muriel
noticed that my breath wasn't doing too
well
and I was like okay there's something
definitely wrong with my teeth yeah I
went to go get it fixed I got a deep
cleaning by the way the worst experience
in my [ __ ] life if you've never had
your teeth deep clean before yeah
they're basically stripping the spirit
out of your teeth here pretty much and I
had no [ __ ] clue and you know me
being like a dude you know the the
dental hygienist asked me they go oh do
you want like a novocaine shot or do you
just want your your gums numb like well
what do most people do let me get the
novocaine shot but it's really not that
bad
yeah you lying [ __ ] you [ __ ] lying
[ __ ] so I was like give me the [ __ ]
numbing [ __ ] dude I'm not a [ __ ] give
me that [ __ ] give me the shot give me
the [ __ ] shot now dude like it hurts
so [ __ ] bad yeah but ever since I
went to the dentist after that I noticed
when people have bad gums can't I can't
help but notice number one when it's
very puffy that means there's a lot of
bacteria in there and so we were at this
theater watching a quiet place there's
this dude that was sitting there and it
was an Asian guy - [ __ ] guy making us
look bad [ __ ] on the guy you he just
sat there and his breath was so bad I
was a seat over to him with the seat gap
in between us he was sitting there with
his mouth open like this oh hell naw it
smelled like decayed tooth yeah I had to
move two seats over cuz it was so
[ __ ] bad and now I can't help it I
just want to walk up to people and say
hey you need to go to a dental hygienist
get a deep cleaning because your teeth
are diseased your teeth are individual
sacks of garbage yeah and it needs to be
clean now
I think bad breaths are like one of the
hardest things to deal with oh that and
be oh yeah yeah oh [ __ ] oh my god
[ __ ] Beale don't even get me started
on that [ __ ] bro and people don't I
don't understand how people don't know
they smell you know for a big guy - as
you know when I was a lot bigger I made
sure that I didn't smell it just because
I know as a big dude yeah we're already
fat smelly exactly I don't want to be
smelly fat guys I just want to be fat
guy yeah
you don't want to be sweaty smelly fat
exactly if you're sitting down and you
have flabs you better put some deodorant
in those flags you get it all up in
there yes right you know just hide your
Snickers there you [ __ ] leave a
deodorant stick in there as well it was
bad dude there's somebody that uh that
all of us know too that has such bad
well you don't really know this guy but
within another group of friends like I
smell so bad and you know for me to like
I think generally for friends I like to
clown on them but for me because I'm not
as close to this person within the group
yeah I can't even bring up to the dude
layer hey you smell like [ __ ] yeah like
I want to tell him yeah like not in a
way of making fun of them but I want to
let him know that he smells like a
carcass like I don't it is to the point
where he says what's up to me I'm just
like don't even come near me do ya i'ma
say what's up to you from a [ __ ]
niceness
is that bad it's that [ __ ] bad like
I'm talking about so Khalif saw him yeah
at a mutual party an intial friend's
party yeah and right after he came back
he goes yo did you smell I wasn't there
he goes did he always smell like that
was like I already know who you're
talking about bro
he goes dude he smelled soap I couldn't
be next in he said he hasn't [ __ ]
fixed it and none of his friends are
telling him oh my god like you should
[ __ ] tell her for damn sure man
that's like you're not doing him any
favors by letting him just go around
smelling like that yeah dude like it
doesn't even make sense like I'm like
how do you smell this [ __ ] bed do you
not know and it got to a point where I
was thinking like Oh is he going through
like some financial issues maybe can
that of life so something like I like if
you're going through some financial
issues I divide you I could buy you 80
pounds of Dial soap right now and it's
gonna cost $13 that'll last you forever
yeah you know but either Peter he
doesn't know or people aren't mentioning
to him but it's to the point where if
you say what's up to me and I got and I
gotta keep a stiff arm out yeah to keep
you away yeah smell pretty [ __ ] bad
they're yummy tell you some funny [ __ ] I
think I was in like fourth grade or
something fourth or fifth grade and
there was this one kid a guy who
developed a lot quicker than a lot of us
so he like he grew a lot taller and he
already started like getting hairy
like all in his arms and she liked to
start to get like a little bit of a
mustache and so Mexican Armenian yeah he
was Mex okay yeah
and then Mexican Russia and then he
started to have Bo right and everybody
used to kind of clown on him but then
like I don't think he really recognized
that he had Bo cuz he was still a kid
you've got people being mean yeah
because you know we're [ __ ] what like
10 years old at that age right [ __ ] up
[ __ ] his one point the teacher got every
but the guys all deodorants for like a
Christmas present so it was like she was
trying to be coy about it yes
unintentionally singling him out even
more you know I just would have took him
aside it's like hey yeah Jose come here
for a second u.s. mooie-mooie
yes stinky how did the East LA for what
the [ __ ] [ __ ] come around you're
smelling fool yeah so yeah that was that
was kind of cold man I was like I don't
think she realized what she just did
right but you know for me to it's like
that's probably a move on would have
been oh hey everybody I got everybody a
Costco supply worth of Old Spice only
for the guys wouldn't had ladies two
ladies including no but that's the thing
she did it it was just yeah I think I
think she like kind of framed it around
him you know like everybody we're going
you guys are going through a point now
where your body is changing and stuff
and so this is something that you know
you're gonna have to introduce into your
like daily routine like she tried to be
really kind of like PC about it you know
and just like trying not to hurt
anybody's feelings like dude everybody
[ __ ] those hears everybody knows who
your outing out dude you're [ __ ]
talking about head although smelly ass
armpits yeah that's what's think though
that was they I didn't want to [ __ ]
play back my mom always made sure that
before I left the school I took a nice
hot shower and before I went to sleep I
took a shower too because kids smelled
all four dams people are touching you
you're sweating all day my mom made sure
that I don't show
yeah it was one of those things that
actually started to look forward to yeah
till this day I can't start my day
without taking a shower really well I'm
kind of oily anyways so so twice a day
there Weiss a day so I don't shampoo
every ok every cuz it'll [ __ ] up your
hair yeah but um like I definitely have
to like wash myself maybe that's why I
don't have Bo is because I consistently
wash myself
yeah but I I can't stand that [ __ ] I
can't stand being the smelly guy dude I
remember like on the basketball team man
there was this one cat like this
[ __ ] had such bad but here's the
thing I'm pretty sure here you use
deodorant but like it came out of his
pores like so from his other person like
we'd be playing and I'd be guarding him
and then like his forearm would like
touch me here and I smell like oh my
[ __ ] god what are you gonna tell the
dealer oh yes [ __ ] buddy this will
just eat cheese all day what is he what
is it what does his diet consists of I
don't know I don't know but he was an
Indian cat though probably was Bo and
I'm not saying this to be disrespectful
player you know cuz Sacramento has a lot
of Indian folks and a lot of Indian
homies like Indian food has a lot of
sponge spices and so like a lot of the
Indian homies they would actually cook
Indian food in the garage away from
everything else yeah and that stove in
the garage was always lying with foil
yeah spice is stuck on right right so he
probably was just next to the food all
the time maybe we just come out of his
[ __ ] pores because I know that
if I can certain like garlic smell it on
me oh really I'm eating like heavy
garlic for like weeks I don't know that
[ __ ] on me yeah so let's smell like
garlic I used to be like bro man [ __ ]
smells dude like do something about this
man it was good though huh no he wasn't
good Annie smell like [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know yeah well I mean I'm gonna try and
be mean but to me it smell like [ __ ]
yeah I was just like bro come on man
it's hard to deal with men and that's
not even fair that means he's just
that's like a legal defense it's doing
chemical warfare [ __ ] like throwing
this sweater [ __ ] come near our like
the sweat on you you son of a [ __ ]
yeah I mean it was high school yeah this
isn't high school but I want to kind of
back up to that goes topic again do you
believe in aliens I want to believe in
aliens I find it very hard to believe
that we are the only like sentient form
of life in the whole [ __ ] universe
yeah because if the if the universe is
so expansive than what what makes us
believe that were the only things out
there huh recently they had that that
oddly shaped meteor that passed by earth
and they actually believed that that was
an alien spaceship really because of the
trajectory that so I guess like it came
to earth and the trajectory was like off
it starts speeding up really fast when
it got to earth really so they they
think people are making speculations
that that was actually an alien
spaceship well okay so then the next
step one that let's say aliens are real
do you think they're a kind race or like
I think they're just like us they just
trying to figure it out like what's
what's up with these [ __ ] people but
but if they can do space travel I mean I
think it's safe to assume that they're
way more intelligent than we are right
if they're doing space travel right
let's just say this yeah they're doing
space travel and they're so like
malicious yeah they would have [ __ ]
killed us by now
but they would have roasted us that's
the thing I'm I'm thinking if they are
the malicious type like maybe they look
at us and we're just like so far beneath
them they're like it's not even worth it
well [ __ ] will obliterate these guys
in a sec doing it to ourselves anyway
destroying the earth ya know what they
look maybe they just look just like us
well have you ever seen the movie with
um
what was it called like science well no
not science the crop circle movie no not
that not the crop circle but that [ __ ]
was whack as [ __ ] with Joaquin Phoenix
yeah yeah that was whack as [ __ ] the M
night Shyamalan movie ya know though I'm
talking about the one with thinking
about smelly Indians I'm just kidding oh
you suck the only thing is thinks that
about him is know that you know the one
what's dead the redhead actress [ __ ]
it's the one where they have a glass and
these like aliens are like this smoke
form and they like communicate like
through the glass
by creating shapes uh I had no idea what
the focus well do now is it although
rival the rival Independence Day
speaking of that movie was the [ __ ]
[ __ ] man then they have a second one
Wells Marable Tara would you do that why
would you make why would you even make
it if Will Smith said no I'm not gonna
do it that's it Will Smith was
Independence Day and men in black huh yo
yo Pam I forget about that [ __ ] I I
remember I heard him talk about it he so
he did men in black I think instead of
matrix that's the movie that he decides
he was supposed to be Neil did you know
that he would have been a terrible meal
he would have been even acknowledged
that too like that I would have made a
terrible Neil you know and then Morpheus
was supposed to be Val Kilmer that would
have been the worst movie like Val
Kilmer and Morpheus says [ __ ] out of
here yes I was like the [ __ ] was trying
to cast issued that casting director
should be killed
yeah cuz Will Smith has this thing about
it on his a YouTube channel about him
explaining yeah how the witch house key
brothers approached them and then so
sisters now my friend oh that's right
the hotel ski sisters isn't what chassis
or wachowski I think it was house key no
but anyway he's basically was saying
like the pitch to them was like okay so
imagine you're in a room and then you
jump up and then the camera does this
gotta look like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about he's like nothing he went
from one successful franchise to another
success he's not really missing out out
for sure I mean he's [ __ ] Will Smith
you know but arguably I will say that
the first matrix till this day still
stands to the test of time oh I'm sure
one of the best like action films or
sightly action films I've ever seen yeah
cuz that when that [ __ ] camera
there's that 360 shut blew your mind you
know
yeah they set up like so many different
cameras yeah yeah yeah you know what's
interesting
I'm not sure if a lot of people know
this but you know the watch out the
Wachowski sisters thank God they were
sued for so if you wish how which
matrices right now hello buddy
because I don't know the plural of
matrixes uh-huh
which matrix movies did you like one
exactly yes so this is what it was yeah
so if you notice number two number three
sucked
[ __ ] convoluted as hell man dumb as
[ __ ] right this is what happens somebody
actually came out saying that the
Wachowski sisters uh-huh stole that
movie that script that script from this
person
oh so people don't know what happened
but it was actually settled out of court
uh-huh so that means you know they
settle out of court and that girl got
paid off Wow that girl a guy I forgot
who it was yeah they were sued because
that was my new scene that person was
saying it was their script yeah and they
stole it yeah and so the the thing that
becomes doesn't that that doesn't really
bode well for them is how terrible
matrix 2 & 3 was and how he had nothing
to do with the first one they couldn't
continue the [ __ ] story it just got
like so [ __ ] convoluted that I think
there was I think everybody was
thoroughly confused by the by the end of
the trilogy and had to actually sit and
think about it and like figure out what
the [ __ ] does this mean still did it
make sense yeah and so to that person's
credit even if it was settled out of
court and people don't want to believe
it to me the proof is in the [ __ ]
pudding yeah matrix 2 & 3 yeah did it
make any sense and it didn't align with
the first one it was hot garbage it was
like somebody completely new wrote wrote
the film yeah it's almost like they
didn't know what to do with it and that
I was so disappointed because the first
one was like so wrong you know and then
like I was like oh dude the second one's
gonna be [ __ ] sick and then the
second one was kind of like you know I
don't really get it and the third one
was just like what the [ __ ] was this it
didn't make any [ __ ] sense at all do
you think there was ever a trilogy of
movies where all three were like on
point the Lord of the Rings
I'm not a big Lord of the Rings fan so I
watched it because like I have friends
who are super into and they're like you
gotta watch it and the Harry Potter
series I haven't seen did urs you are a
sinner you are a sinner dude you are you
are somebody who has denounced God in
his life I never watched a single Harry
Potter I've seen part of the first one I
think
and then that's about it why would you
only watch apart what was so bad about
it how could you hate Harry Potter I
just I can't I can't like connect with
it I'm pretty sure [ __ ] thugs watch
Harry Potter dude you don't like Harry
Potter what's wrong with Harry Potter I
don't know if I don't like it I just
like what I saw from it which is I don't
know it just really didn't hook me what
but I never read the books yeah I never
read the Harry I mean I read like the
first two or something but still even
that I think this the the series is
great man maybe I love magic as [ __ ]
though yeah I think magics dope - I
don't like real magic I'm talking about
like a [ __ ] dude come up to you like
how many quarters do you get out of your
[ __ ] my face I'm talking about like
fantasy fantasy magic right when you're
just like you know making people fun
exploding their face off doing this with
[ __ ] was so [ __ ] dope yeah when I went
to London my sister's a huge Harry
Potter fan so I went to the Harry Potter
store and first of all there was a line
to get into the store I was like Heil
[ __ ] Nam and you're gonna make me
wait in line to spend money right now
and then once I got in there started
looking around I had no [ __ ] clue
what these characters were not and like
there's like these schools so I didn't
know what cuz I didn't want to get my
sister or something character-based and
she's like all I [ __ ] hate that
character you know so I was like okay
she wanted to be Gryffindor bro no what
the [ __ ] me if you made her a Slytherin
she would have been pissed I have no
[ __ ] idea what you're talking about
so I just got it like some general
Hogwarts [ __ ] just like the school of
Hogwarts I think that's the safe side
I'm a play to say good [ __ ] ain't cheap
bro they were like I paid like [ __ ]
20-something bucks for a bookmark you
know what the [ __ ] yeah
it had like the the school of Hogwarts
like the what do you call it the shield
or the the crest the school yeah yeah
and then it was like kind of made in
like metal and it was did you not like
it dude
cuz I don't know it I just never
interested me man Hagrid bro man you
know I can't be friends anymore
now everybody says that's a reaction
every time when I see who else hasn't
watched Harry Potter
Marial for dad I'm surprised about I
would think she's like a huge Harry
Potter fan I know
that's a big Disney fan like I was left
her what she's just not interested in it
her way I don't know if she ever had the
opportunity or she was i I think like
when there was like a huge Harry Potter
she might have been traveling at the
time so she didn't really have any legs
in any country and at that point so I
don't think that watching that film
wasn't important oh I see so I just
never just never really caught on with
her but she hasn't watched Harry Potter
and people always give her [ __ ] and
rightfully so you can hate her for it
she hasn't read the books to him kissing
no I mean I really I read the first like
1 or 2 like harry potter and the
sorcerer's bone or something like that
or some [ __ ] like that that's not it's
our source or stone that's what it is
the title of it
no it's big you know what that's my
fault because I used to make fun of the
the title so much I used to make all
sexual in it anyone knows about it was a
Harry Potter the Sorcerer's bone there
was like the Goblet of desire it was
like the Goblet of Fire was the original
one see but at least at least like it
sounds from from what I hear from the
fans that they did somewhat of justice
to the books right but then it's like
when you're talking about [ __ ] like
Aladdin where you [ __ ] take a Disney
classic and you're gonna turn it into a
live-action movie and you [ __ ] put
out that god-awful whatever disgrace of
a CG Genie and the trait like your
fellow Will Smith yeah but like when you
saw that trailer didn't it [ __ ] like
couldn't you tell the face was not
moving in sync with the body it was like
slightly off there's like certain films
like specifically Disney 2d films I just
don't want a live-action oh that's what
I'm saying man I don't know what the
like he looks pretty [ __ ] though they
don't get the [ __ ] out of here bro like
I think the only reason why a lion king
looks dope is because the cast seems
pretty [ __ ] dough may I see the new
trailer though I didn't know there was a
trailer yeah I don't know don't you give
me those [ __ ] I don't don't give me
the Harry Potter I hey hey we're gonna
we're gonna revisit this conversation
after the trailers [ __ ] don't is it
yeah it's [ __ ] sick you know what was
a fire ass trailer that I was shocked
about that new frozen trailer
you see that [ __ ] where somebody's
trying to like move past his ocean and
swim past but it looks [ __ ] intense I
haven't seen the first frozen the first
frozen is I would never say this to
Mariel better not like it see a big fan
she actually went out when we were first
going out yes she because she always
wanted to go in Disney and Disney
Animation is actually where she's
working at right now yeah I said one bad
thing about frozen I thought she I'm not
even [ __ ] [ __ ] you I think she
broke up with me yeah she on that level
yeah she's like don't ever say anything
bad about yeah Wow I was like some
serious [ __ ] that's for her it has a
very special place in her heart because
that's that was the film I think that
really sparked her interest to get into
Disney Animation uh-huh you know and III
understand like it's like for her if she
said like she didn't like The Fresh
Prince of bel-air I'm [ __ ] 300 kicker
and that's in the [ __ ] belly button
this is one thing to be like hold
something dear near to your heart but
then it's like everybody has their
opinion on it like you you know you
don't have to like it not in a
relationship bro that's why you haven't
been in a long-term relationship your
that doesn't mean [ __ ] opinions don't
mean [ __ ] in a relationship dude there's
like certain things you just aren't a
left touch frozen's one of them yeah cuz
I used to get mad at her all the time I
would tell her like why why does it
matter I'm allowed to have an opinion on
this thing and you shouldn't take it
personally yeah and no matter how much
how logic logically sound that argument
is it doesn't [ __ ] matter because
there's an emotional attachment to the
thing that they're talking about so it
just doesn't [ __ ] matter and I had
the hardest time wrapping my head around
yeah I think it just comes down to the
point of okay you know what I love this
person enough where I care about what
she cares about and if that's that
important to her I don't have to express
my opinion on it
I'll just let it be you know I still
talk mad [ __ ] about it behind her back
though I don't you know why it's cuz I
didn't I didn't really like the music
because usually when I watched like
Disney Animation said like [ __ ] with the
music hell yeah it's just the music I
didn't I didn't like as much man that
whole let it go let it go
three Disney movies why'd you wait right
I think you're gonna slap the [ __ ] like
a [ __ ] backyard never see somebody go
like this Fox's top three like that
don't ever top three likes anyway this
is only for Disney movies yeah let's see
definitely a whole new world is deaf it
has to be up there just because it
sounds sexual as fuller it's a whole new
world
Aladdin [ __ ] Oh what the [ __ ] it's
called Aladdin though no I bet you make
this top three movies I don't remember
Disney movie called a whole new top
three would be if it's 2d is actually
sword in the stone is one of them whoa
okay it's something is one that I grew
up with a very dying laughing or two the
stone Lion King yeah sure yeah that has
to be in the list liking an Aladdin dude
I'm still liking a letter yeah I think
mine is Lion King Aladdin and probably
goofy movie Oh goofy movie that's right
height is you know that should soda see
me because in the goofy movie you
remember when he cracked open that nut
there was gold inside huh I was walking
around the neighborhood looking for that
[ __ ] and then when I finally found one
of those trees yeah I cracked it open no
gold no gold I was so mad and it was so
hard to break yeah with my tiny little
[ __ ] eighty pound body I was trying
to crush this [ __ ] and there was no gold
inside yeah do you know that uh you know
a power line from the goofy movie was a
Tevin Campbell he's the one who yeah bro
he's saying that [ __ ] he was the one who
[ __ ] did a power lines voice what
yeah and then if you see they had on
YouTube they have like this reunion of
like the goofy movie cast members or
the writers and [ __ ] like that they got
Tevin Campbell to come and perform live
what yeah it's it's kind of sad because
he's like old now and then like he has
two janky dancers next but I was like
amen
you got to make your money but you got
to do that it's crazy cuz those
childhood films they were really good at
making you buy [ __ ] because I wanted
Cheez Whiz so bad next yes yeah I wanted
cheese was so bad and it looks so
delicious though and I remember when I
bought she's waited and I finally had it
on a cracker I spit it out I was like
what is this garbage
how could he eat is so delicious it
might my dad was looking at me idiot is
a [ __ ] cartoon dumbass which is true
like I just thought he made it look so
good he's just spraying into his mouth
yeah I guess nothing a max check it out
bro the leaning tower of Shiva the only
time Cheez Whiz is hella good is on a
[ __ ] Philly cheesesteak oh hell yes
so [ __ ] good alien what I think the
only good one in LA is booze yeah I've
been saying it man and it's a Korean cat
that owns it yeah I actually did a video
for them Oh for real yeah man he hooked
it up yeah I wanted to do you get a
passion that when you when you get there
like a free sub-caste I doubt that
simply because I like booze Philly
cheesesteak yeah and they're a marketing
person hit me up I don't know who that
person is I don't
hopefully it's not his wife or anything
yeah she was terrible bad communication
if you're his wife or something
great job [ __ ] on pointers to the
wrong location and everything really
great terrible communications you great
job I love you but do booze Philly
cheesesteak out in k-town oh they have
another one out in Silver Lake that was
that one right yeah that's the first
okay and so this dude's back story is
that he grew up in Philly and because
when he grew up in Philly number one his
parents wanted to like start a business
and I guess like he started it for them
or something and you know his dad got
tired and want to do a business anybody
well I got this thing but I wanted to
make Philly cheesesteaks out here
because he couldn't get a good
cheesesteak out yeah and that's just
basically the story of a lot of great
whole
while restaurants make stuff that they
want to eat first yeah so he couldn't
get a good Philly cheesesteak yeah and
so he created himself and then you got
booth Philly yeah
there was actually a pretty good one
when I was going to school in Irvine
there was a place called Philly's best
yeah yeah that place used to be good but
then yeah an LA there just wasn't really
like any good Philly cheesesteak place
and then I ran and we came across boos I
think like I don't know somewhere in my
mid I don't even know if mid 20s or some
point at that time and I went to try it
I was like oh this is [ __ ] delicious
I didn't even know about booze until
they moved to a spot yes that's when I
was fat fat yeah I see booze all the way
were they there when you were living
there yeah write that as a snack yeah
and by the way it's really hard to eat
that as a snack yeah cause it's like
2,000 calories per each sandwich but I
didn't give up oh yeah back then you're
I was I was a hefty boy you were and we
were just talking about that last night
cuz like what Dave cuz like you know I
see him regularly so like he was losing
weight a little bit at a time so I
hadn't realized like he was slowly
losing weight and all of a sudden one
day just like what the [ __ ] you lost mad
weight but it was just like a slow and
steady progress right yeah I'm miss
booze like I miss it you know it's weird
cuz I read a review on booze Philly
cheesesteak and this person wrote like I
don't know why people like this so much
it's so greasy it's so heavy with that
that's a [ __ ] cheesesteak [ __ ] the
[ __ ] are you talking about man that's
like complaining that waters wet yeah
you know what cheesesteak is supposed to
be greasy you supposed to be dank as
[ __ ] and it's supposed to sit in your
stomach yes that's what a cheese steaks
for it's not that than you it's just a
regular steak sandwich yeah the paper
needs to be all greasy and [ __ ] you
know yeah man booze yo shout-out to
booze man shout-out to booze that's just
[ __ ] delicious and [ __ ] that guy
whatever whoever he is out there in the
world [ __ ] that guy how about the review
yeah it was a [ __ ] blonde white girl
not even from LA cuz I looked at that
person's profile I was so upset I was so
upset [ __ ] find out who this person is
I'm like character profile person yo and
and I'll tell you this too I I wrote a
review for booze so I write reviews on
Yelp but I don't use
my actual name I use a separate knee and
I only give people five or four stars
that's it because I don't I don't really
believe in tearing down a business and
they're not doing well because they're
gonna disappear either way right and I'm
not in the business of making somebody's
look bad because it's their living it's
like how about if they give you like
[ __ ] abysmal service like like the
worst kind that abysmal service has to
be pretty bad like they would have to
like come out to me a bit looks and here
you [ __ ] pan face good
I don't want your flat face munching on
my food like [ __ ] out of here yeah I
don't even know how you chew at your
flat ass face I want to even see that
food with your [ __ ] yeah it's like it
would be on some [ __ ] like that but if
somebody was just like a rude waiter
then I'm not gonna give them a bad
review just because that that waiter
isn't a reflection of the business per
se maybe yeah and also because if I like
the food most likely they're gonna get a
good review and I'll mention about the
poor service but I'm not gonna give them
a three-star because the service is bad
because if I [ __ ] with the food I'm
gonna come back either way no like the
only time that I wrote a review was
because like the service was just like
horrific ly bad and the manager was not
even willing to do any kind about it
yeah
and she would you say come back yep you
know that's what it is you know what the
funny [ __ ] is is like chunji Kaba now
the word [ __ ] here in America is like so
offensive people take like so much
offense to it if you call somebody a ton
it doesn't even sound bad to me but it's
like British slang to learn yeah like
they say it's so like freely yeah you
know that backwards [ __ ]
yeah and like you know they called each
other like mates [ __ ] like you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know like it's so commonplace but I
don't know why it's so bad here like
what about like okay we call people or
each other like [ __ ] right yeah
[ __ ] of kind of offensive but not
that bad you go you you escalate it to
cut oh yeah I feel like even sometimes
cut is worse than [ __ ] yeah you know
it's arguably what I would say it is
worse how people treat it you know
I think it's like in another category
you know yeah like it's it's a in a
category with a few words that are just
like extremely offensive but I just
don't understand where that came from
III don't know either man it doesn't
sound so it never really offended me
maybe I don't know maybe it's more
offensive to a girl yeah no that's wrong
even to a girl like okay well if you're
just kind of saying like it's it's just
another word for like you vagina yeah
but but I think it's like the
connotation behind it well that's kind
of saying too like if somebody came up
to me and said you're a female dog
versus somebody else called me a [ __ ]
you say that [ __ ] to me to piss me off
a female she wouldn't call me a [ __ ]
like that but it was so funny because I
curse a lot you know I'm trying to stop
I know that I'm like no you're not I'm
trying not to use it as frequently as
before but I still choose to use it all
the time because I love cursing he makes
me feel good it feels on my soul so Mary
oh I guess she didn't really understand
the the varying levels of cursing and
how offensive it could be yeah so I
should you not we were joking around and
she said something really stupid and I
was like yeah like you jackass and she
looks at me she goes oh okay [ __ ] and
it would just went dead silent between
us I looked at a little what did you
just call me she goes well you cursed at
me yeah I was like hold on a second
[ __ ] you know you know jackass and
[ __ ]
are two different things yeah she goes
what do you mean they're both curse
words no there's levels to this [ __ ] you
don't just you don't just like I said I
just dumbfounded
yeah look how dare you yeah and she
didn't understand she goes well you call
me that's offensive as hell I was like
jackass is not that's actually on the
lower tier of cursing yeah it's it's
almost like negligible and almost can't
get offended if somebody calls you a
jackass yeah for her when she called me
back sat there just just shocked yeah
well you know what I think to be fair
though whether a guy or a girl calls
another dude a [ __ ] guys take it kind
of personally you know of course
especially if the guy looks
substantially weaker than you but but
for me too it's like such a big self
motivator if like I don't
want to do something or I'm not in the
mood to do something
I start talking to myself and I said
don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and I go I in a [ __ ] so will you being
a [ __ ] right now is like I no [ __ ]
baby like I'll have that same
conversation but it goes away different
because you're a little bit early you
can't talk to me like that I'll do
whatever the [ __ ] I want upon asleep the
conversation no I that that's how I get
myself motivated I might you being a
[ __ ] right now and I'm like ain't no
[ __ ] [ __ ]
well that's just because like you know I
found this out too and I might have
mentioned this before but I feel like a
lot of the people that I'm around tend
to get motivated through that through
negative reinforcement I think it's just
because how our parents were yeah but
what I found out too
growing up was that even though I'm like
that my older brother is not like that
my brother is a man of positive reinvest
true John's a very warm guy yeah he's
he's that pause and so for me you know
it's so funny I was trying to motivate
him I mean I would call him Michael stop
being a little [ __ ] don't be a [ __ ]
you know just kind of motivated I was
breaking this guy down and my mom told
me she goes hey like I know that you
know you guys were both raised by me
when I raised both are you very
differently she goes he doesn't get
motivated lately I can't talk to him
like that man we were talking about
trying to [ __ ] encourage him
I'm telling me the loser you're like
getting him depressed and putting him to
like a low place in his life yeah dude
I'm like dude do you see that [ __ ]
car step in front of it when it's moving
yeah yeah you know like I but I'm trying
to motivate him because that's how I
motivate it so somebody says like hey
don't be a [ __ ] puss a cup and do
this [ __ ] yeah you know be motivated you
know III I tend that tends to be the
fuel yeah for my flame yeah but for him
it's an ice bucket of water that just
dousing it over a [ __ ] campfire and I
didn't know that [ __ ] so I would try to
motivate in that way and I was verbally
pushing him here's a verbal abuse I had
no [ __ ] clue
absolutely none and my mom explained to
me and I felt like trash I was like
David so how [ __ ] dare you do your
own brother to my own brother I thought
I was doing him a favor do yeah yeah
yeah waking him up and then pushing him
over and said
and kicking him in the neck I deserved
that cuz your [ __ ] skull that's right
do your [ __ ] job and do a better job
at it before I spit in your eye yeah
everybody gets motivated differently but
you know like I think people like us we
just got to kind of talk that [ __ ] to
ourselves you know cuz I don't know man
if it's like I can't I can't get
motivated with like oh you know you're
doing a good job because it makes me
feel complacent yeah exactly exactly I
feel like I'm not doing it it's cuz
here's the thing I think there's a sense
of like ourselves where it's like even
if somebody is saying oh you're doing a
good job in your mind or in your in that
in your heart even you don't think so
well you like I could be doing more
though I could be doing better yeah I
know and so you don't even want to take
that you just deflect it like nah and
then it's like you [ __ ] though oh [ __ ]
it that's another hour that was super
[ __ ] fast you know what by the way I
have to drive back home and I'm gonna be
looking over my shoulder now I hate that
[ __ ] dude I hate when people tell me
ghost stories because when I'm in the
car yeah that's the most vulnerable
place that you could ever be at you're
talking about in your car you can't do
anything and all I do is look at like
the rearview mirror to see if somebody
stares at my [ __ ] it the other way to
just turn it yeah but I needed to drive
alright well here you go here's my good
spirit and I just gave it to you anyways
guys that concludes this episode of
genius brain podcast remember this is a
very interactive space man you'll ask
questions in the comments below if
you're watching this on youtube or any
kind of video platform but remember we
are on every audio platform I don't
think we're on soundcloud but we are on
stitcher we're on iTunes podcast Spotify
everything else and just look up genius
brain that's genius brain without a
space
Adric where can they find you again
Instagram ed to EDT wo secret society
scrt society comm check it out thanks
for tuning in y'all alright y'all we'll
see y'all next time
alright peace